if your knowledge of engineering stops
with putting batteries in a TV remote
you might try fiddling around with a
little bits kit for a day it's basically
a set of electronic parts that snap
together with Lego like ease in fact the
set is easy enough for little kids to
use which is the idea behind little bits
the small modules snap together
magnetically to form circuits and the
polarity of the magnets keeps your kids
were you more likely from trying to put
them together the wrong way the bits are
color-coded to help kids know what's
what it's this like way to learn the
basics like power sources come first and
inputs come before outputs once you
figure it out bask in the glow of your
engineering triumphs